let me ask you because you're on Kauai
the island and because of like you know
the things they're shooting up in Alaska
yeah
oh yeah yeah because you would think
that in a remote place like Hawaii they
would seize
this flying objects have you seen any
yeah we've seen something that I have
the video of by being real I'm dead
serious um apparently they're saying it
was the jet
thrusters uh um on a freaking missile or
whatever you know the things that break
off
yeah from 2008. let me get this straight
let me get this straight let me get this
let me get this straight okay can you
decipher no I can decipher it all right
so what he's saying is you know when you
see like um a movie like Apollo 13 or
whatever and then yeah there's things
that break off from the ship yeah yes
you got one of those yeah all of
Hawaii's seen it from 2008 and it just
fell down just two years ago or so two
years ago it re-entered our atmosphere
and where did it fall to I don't know
where it fell to all right here we go
look like in the sky bra do you you guys
ever play um uh Super Smash Bros okay
yeah
Super Smash Bros the original the
Nintendo 64. yeah yeah so you know when
you choose Star Fox that map yeah yeah
you know that ship that you're fighting
on yeah
you saw that
oh you're saying the map okay got it so
it was just lights right
it was just it was just a bunch of
lights but in the shape of in 2008 so
the phones weren't even that great at
capturing yeah you know what bro you
didn't say you didn't see wait hold on
100 years ago no no this is two years
you want to see the vid
I'll show you the video I'll show you
the vid now after whatever okay so you
have a fear of that phone yeah I I have
Avid it's not as good as the other vids
that were posted though okay all right
so the ones that are good that you are
posted what are what do I see when I'm
looking at guy you see uh what looks
like it's it's just like a bunch of like
flashing lights like just passing
through yeah well but we're just seeing
the thing that part of a rocket ship
that we've launched right or you're
saying that it's extraterrestrial no no
no no I'm not saying what it is or isn't
I'm saying what the newspaper came out
and what NASA said it was so what you're
saying is something different we thought
we'd seen one [__] one like just
but then the people the newspaper came
out and said oh no what you guys seen
was
um oh my gosh it's like I know they're
lying is what you're saying they come
off right well that's interesting the
interesting thing is is that thing came
off
from a missile launch in 2008 yeah two
years ago it reacted they said it
happens all the time so it was just the
first to make any sense does it make any
sense yeah but also if it re-enters the
atmosphere like what is the risk of it
like Just landing on like a [__] like
building house yeah that's I'm like oh
sure well it was weird because it didn't
come straight down it was coming well at
least not towards Kauai it was just like
it was just flying by you know and then
Oahu seen it like a lot of the different
Islands seen it oh my God which means it
would have had to travel towards Big
Island from Kauai right have you guys
heard of the horns what's the Horn Guy I
so dramatic the way you did it no no I
have you know about the horns
it's the same look that you did but the
Luke Skywalker say you don't know what
the [__] you were talking about so stop
doing the look what does that look do
you know what I'm talking about the
horns all over the world all over the
world wait why I don't know what that is
in remote places over the world people
have taken their camera or whatever out
right on the nice phones yeah and have
captured horns
in the sky what kind of horns like gold
horns no no no no no no no we're not now
we're not talking about [__] you know
me oh goat
why did you say that yeah we're talking
about we're talking trumpets that's just
not like oh those Stars if you connect
them is a horn no no that's not what
they're talking about
is that no no we're not talking to no
we're talking about this audio
this is Broad day broad day you hear
in the distance but it's like okay
that's 15 oh that's not what that's not
the ones I heard
no talk about some of them are like that
what is your sound some are like
right but like nine right here here
Sweden
in Michigan another trumpet-like sound
in British Columbia Canada Dr Glenn
McPherson wow that's just happening in
the sky it just sounds like the pride of
America cruise ship no it's a cruise
ship these are happening where there's
no buildings or nothing
really yeah and it sounds like maybe
like an animal that's looking for a mate
it's not like you know what I mean
I Wanna [__] Yeah I mean you think I
wanna [__]
why would an animal do that it's
sometimes like when if they have to
vocalize that far for me it could be
like oh yeah yeah it sounds good yeah
you're very good is that you out there
that's how when I land on this island
immediately I'm like oh yeah
yeah but my point is is that it's not
that I don't think it's something that's
unexplainable yeah but I think it's
alien in nature
so you're a Believer aren't you well you
know it's hard not to believe it's hard
not to say that there isn't yeah
something you know but I can't until
there's some real evidence my personal
evidence right like I didn't see what
you saw you know I mean Kauai whatever
but if I witnessed that maybe I would
believe but you know I I don't I'm a
little skeptical but I'm open I'm open
to it say man like even after seeing
that I'm like okay whoa what is that and
then when they said what it was I'm like
oh that doesn't I hate when they lie
yeah yeah yeah I I wish newspapers we
don't know either yeah hold yeah just be
honest yeah but then like the idea that
I mean yes that would be nice but I
think people would freak out